the Border Patrol boat crew just located
a body floating in the Rio Grande River
no
it's a young boy I'm a teenager for now
the cause of death is unknown but the
crew is faced with a more immediate
problem the body is in the middle of the
river so it's unclear if he's in Mexican
or US jurisdiction so we don't sit here
all night long
we're just going to continue going
towards your body to the US site that
way we know where it is is not going
anywhere wait until the authorities come
and they came not completely recovered
we're gonna have to clear that brush
there doable agents clear the brush so
the recovery team can gain access to the
river
big enough here where they can get the
stretcher a gurney or something like
that so they can complete their recovery
wanna beat it just up from the landing
doctor me ten yards five coming up on it
that's good
once on the USI crewmembers try to
figure out how he died it's hard to tell
right now because it's facing down there
he's probably been underneath the water
for quite some time he's wearing jeans
white t-shirt no shoes unknown if he was
trying to make an entry if it's down
here swimming or we don't know what the
story is
agent Scooby uses the newly cleared path
to make his way in from the road looks
like a young kid you know I would say
around 15 16 years old he could very
easily be able to as a meal that mean
that that's a good age they usually get
teenagers somebody that we cannot
prosecute on our side so we if we do get
them we're probably just going to send
them back to Mexico anyways you know
there's a lot of possibilities with no
visible markings of foul play
agents can only speculate if the young
man was an immigrant trying to cross or
a drug smuggler there's also a more
worrying possibility he could be a
victim the growing cartel violence south
of the border
I have a 20 year old at 17 year old and
a 5 year old and just the thought of
knowing that your child is missing where
is he where is she and then to find the
end result that he drowned or she
drowned in the river gasps it would be
very hard very disheartened oh when you
put the new form on and you're doing
your job you've got to be numb to all
sorts of situations especially when you
encounter something like this because
well affect your judgement affect your
job the recovery team will arrive
shortly to take the body tomorrow a
forensic pathologist will conduct an
autopsy and search for any clues that
could help identify the young man and
reveal how he died